في اطار او في سوريا جمله لم يعد هناك
اسوا مما نعيشه الان تكاد هذه الجمله لا
تفارق شفاه السوريين ممن يقتنون مناطق
نظام الاسد فبعد ازمه المزود او المحروقات
عموما ها هي ازمه جديده تطال سفره
السوريين هذه المره وهي مشكله توفر ماده
الخبز بعد ما توقف نحو 50% من الافران عن
العمل في العاصمه دمشق اصحاب مخابز خاصه
رئيسيه بدمشق اكدوا على عدم قدرتهم في
الاستمرار بالعمل لان الاستمرار يعني
مزيدا من الخسائر بعد ما خفض النظام من
حصه هذه المخابز بنسبه 40% وبالتالي
ارتفاع كبير باسعار المازوت من السوق
السوداء لتشكل هذه الازمه او هذا الكابوس
ان سحب تعبير الاسوا على السوريين منذ عام
2011 ومع اشتداد الازمه وافتقاد الماده
توقف نحو 50% من الافران الخاصه عن العمل
في دمشق و30% خفضت الانتاج و20% لا تتشتري
المحروقات ولكن طبعا باسعار مرتفعه
[موسيقى]